in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 22 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Paulinos, Bishop of Nola.
Our Holy Father Paulinos was born in Bordeaux in about 353 into one of the most important
Roman aristocratic families which possessed immense land and property in Gaul, Campania and Spain.
He received an excellent education from Osonos, the greatest orator of that time, and so excelled
in the art of poetry that he remains honored as one of the greatest poets of the Christian
West.
When he was scarcely fully grown, important political responsibilities were given to him.
He became a member of the Senate, received the title of Consul, and even held the office
of Governor of Campania in 380.
Remaining for some time in Spain, on account of his affairs, he married Tarasia, a rich matron,
and then returned to settle on his estates in Aquitaine, dividing his time between the
administration of his affairs and his literary activities.
His encounters with Saint Victorus of Ruin and Saint Martin of Tours who healed him of an
eye disease as well as a pilgrimage to the tomb of Saint Felix in Nola in Campania, and
above all the salutary influence of Delphineus, Bishop of Bordeaux, made him conscious of
the vanity of his worldly life, and he began to turn towards God.
Baptized by Delphineus at Christmas in 389, he immediately began to lead an ascetic life,
and to detach himself from the things of this world.
After having lived in Spain for four years, he was ordained priest against his will in
Barcelona in 393 because of the pressure exerted by the people who admired his virtues.
The death of his newborn son deepened his conversion and renunciation of the world, and
he began to liquidate his fortune in order to obtain heavenly wealth.
At the cost of my earthly riches, he wrote, I have acquired the right to bear my cross.
I have used my wealth to acquire the hope of heaven, for hope and faith are more precious
than worldly riches.
Then returning to Aquitaine, he freed his slaves, opened his reserves to the poor, and used
the money he had gained from the sale of his land and property to redeem captives and
to help the destitute.
From there he went to Milan, where he met with Saint Ambrose, who he looked on as his spiritual
father, then to Rome, where the admiration that his conversion provoked among many drew upon
him the jealousy of certain of the upper clergy and the Pope himself received him coldly.
Those members of the aristocracy who had remained pagans considered his penitential life in
extravagance and reproached Paulinas for having deprived the state of his services.
While the saint was criticized by the worldly, he was praised by the servants of God.
Saint Martin said about him that he was almost the only person in the world truly to practice
the evangelical councils, while Saint Jerome sent him letters counseling him on the ascetic
life.
Saint Paulinos then retired to Nola, where he organized an ascetic community around the
hospice which he had built for poor pilgrims during his first pilgrimage.
His wife, with whom he had lived as brother and sister since his conversion, settled nearby
and helped him in all his charitable activities.
Strip of all his wealth, he would wear a penitential hair shirt made of camel hair, would eat
in the evening a roughly made loaf to which vegetables and herbs had been added, and give
himself steadfastly to prayer, and to chanting of hymns both day and night.
Each year on the 14th of January, crowds of pilgrims would arrive to celebrate the feast
of Saint Felix in the vast Basilica that Paulinos had built, with its baptistery and numerous
buildings to welcome those who came.
Yet, the reputation of the man of God also drew many visitors, among them devout aristocrats
and ascetics, like Saint Melania, the elder, and later her granddaughter, Saint Melania, the
younger.
His ascetic withdrawal did not cause Paulinos to abandon his poetic activity.
He continued to conduct a vast correspondence with the great personages of the Church of
his time, including Saint Augustine, Saint Ambrose, Saint Sulpissius Severus, as well as those
holding high office in Gaul and Rome, whom he inspired with the Evangelical virtues.
In 409, he was consecrated Bishop of Nola, and had to fulfill his charge in a particularly
troubled epoch.
The following year, after the sacking of Rome, the barbarians penetrated to Nola and seized
the Holy Bishop, who, strengthened by a vision of Saint Felix, courageously stood his ground
before them.
In prison, he sent up the following prayer.
Lord, may I be tortured neither for my gold nor for my silver, for thou knowest where my wealth
is to be found.
It is said that he gave himself as a slave to the barbarians to redeem the young son of
a poor widow, summarizing his activity as a pastor, his biographer wrote.
He did not try to make the people fear him, but labored to make himself loved by everyone.
As he was not ruffled by insults, nothing was able to make him angry.
He never separated justice and mercy, and if he was obliged to administer punishment, he
did it in the manner of a father who educates his children.
His life was an example of every good work, and the way he welcomed everyone was a great
comfort to those who were afflicted.
No one was absent from him without desiring to see him again, and no one who enjoyed
the happiness of speaking with him wished ever to leave him.
The emperors themselves held him in such high honor that they summoned him to a council
at Ravenna, so that he might judge between two rival candidates to succeed Pope Zosimos
in 419.
When the last days of the life of the blessed man arrived, as he was struck down with a very
painful illness in his side, Saint Genuarius and Saint Martin appeared to him to announce
his approaching deliverance.
He celebrated the divine liturgy on an altar placed near his bed, with two bishops who had
come to visit him, and summoned all the penitents whom he had forbidden to approach the altar
to receive Holy Communion.
He then addressed fervent prayer to God, stretching out his arms to heaven.
With the money that a priest had providentially brought, he was able to repay the debt he
had contracted for having clothes made for the poor.
After this, he bade farewell to his clergy, pronouncing the blessing of peace over them,
and gave his soul into God's hands during the night of the 22nd of June in the year 431.
His precious relics lie today in the cathedral in Nola through the prayers of our Holy
mothers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.